hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called
countdown spoilers ahead watch out and
stay safe the movie begins with a few
teenagers sitting around a table at a
house party one of the girls takes out
her phone and shows the group an app
however when another girl tries to find
the same app she comes across a
different one with a similar title named
countdown she then reads the description
of the app which states that it can tell
the exact time of a person's death down
to the last second so the group decides
to turn the app into a drinking game
where one girl named Courtney is
reluctant however when everyone insists
she hesitantly downloads the app and
accepts the terms and conditions
afterwards everyone in the group gets
roughly 20 minutes 70 years except
Courtney who has only three hours to
live but none of them take it seriously
and make her drink all the beer as per
the game's rules just then her boyfriend
Evan shows up and helps her with the
drinks a while later as she leaves the
party it's clear that Evan insists on
driving home even though he is drunk so
she gets out of the car and walks alone
while Evan drives off she then gets a
message from the app saying she has
broken the user agreement that she walks
she notices a figure following her from
behind and walks faster the app then
makes a sound and tells her that she has
no more than two minutes to live
terrified she switches off the phone and
runs into the house Courtney heads
straight to the bathroom to calm herself
but things get even weirder she hears a
curtain movie and when she turns around
an unseen Force takes a hold of her and
hurls her up towards the ceiling
Courtney is then dropped on the bathroom
floor breaking her head meanwhile Evan
is in a car accident where the seat in
which Courtney was supposed to be is
impaled by a tree log the scene then
cuts to a hospital where we can see a
nurse named Quinn delivering food to
patients she then finds a patient in a
closed off section of the hospital and
it's revealed to be Evan so Quinn sits
with him and tries to relax him for his
surgery the next day Heaven shows and
explains to Quinn what the countdown app
is which says that he has only 19 hours
left to live he also tells her about his
girlfriend Courtney and how she died
this makes him believe that he will also
die within the given time which happens
to be when his surgery will take place
however Quinn calms him down and tells
him not to worry about the app and
convinces him to go back to his room on
the way back she bumps into Amy a senior
nurse who asks Quinn to come with her
the hospital staff then surprise her
with a cake as it turns out that she is
now a registered nurse later Quinn gets
a notification on her phone which turns
out to be an ad for the countdown app so
she downloads the app and agrees to the
terms and conditions which mentions that
she has only two days left to live
inside the left Quinn's colleague Dr
Sullivan starts to flirt with her but
she lets him off easy the same night
Quinn has trouble completing her nursing
documents and calls her friend Scott for
help who tells her that she needs a
birth certificate to fill out the form
the scene then cuts to Quinn going to
her parents house to retrieve her birth
certificate and finds it in her late
mother's room just then she hears a
sudden noise from the closet and when
she goes to inspect she finds her little
sister Jordan hiding with her boyfriend
the guy immediately leaves while Quinn
says that she shouldn't do stuff like
this this makes Jordan angry as her
sister doesn't come around to visit
after the death of their mother after
she storms away Quinn is greeted by her
father he inquires if she wants to come
and visit their mother's grave sometime
to which she obliges the following day
Evan is being prepared for his surgery
but he is reluctant as the app says that
he has only three minutes left so he
ditches his surgery and leaves the room
after which he gets a notification from
the app saying that he has broken the
user agreement he then sees a black tall
figure behind him in the mirror but
doesn't find anyone there in real time
the deathly figure then follows him to a
dark staircase all of a sudden Evan uses
the flashlight on his phone and looks up
where he sees a figure in Courtney's
clothes it grabs him and Chucks him down
the staircase right as the countdown
reaches zero shortly after Quinn arrives
at work where Amy informs her about the
incident disturbing her so to get more
information Quinn steals Evan's phone
but realizes that she needs a
fingerprint to unlock it left with no
option she heads to the hospital
Mortuary there she tries to use Evan's
finger but it doesn't work hence she
opens his eyes and finally opens the
phone using face recognition as Quinn
goes through his phone she notices the
countdown which has reached zero later
Quinn realizes that her countdown time
is at the same hour she will meet her
dad and Jordan to go to her mother's
grave so she calls her dad and
immediately cancels her plans as
expected the app says that she has
broken the user agreement and suddenly
she sees a dark figure in the room Quinn
becomes terrified but fortunately it is
only Dr Sullivan who asks for help with
a patient however Quinn ignores him and
leaves the same night Quinn isn't able
to delete the app and surfs the internet
for Solutions she comes across different
cases about the countdown app which
disturbs her so she closes her laptop
and suddenly sees a terrifying dead Evan
on her bed fed up she throws her phone
to the ground breaking it but somehow it
still shows the countdown terrified to
sleep inside Quinn enters her car and
falls asleep in the morning Jordan wakes
her up from outside and the two of them
go to Quinn's apartment her sister finds
the broken phone seeing the countdown
app which says that she has only one day
to live Jordan wants to spend some time
with her sister but when Quinn refuses
stating that it isn't safe she gets
angry and storms off later Quinn goes to
an electronic shop and buys a new phone
she checks to see if the app is there
and is relieved to find that it isn't
however when she is about to leave she
gets a notification from the countdown
app on her new phone she frantically
asks the shopkeeper to delete the app
but he is unable to do so frustrated she
leaves the shop and gets in her car
while A customer from the store named
Matt asks the shopkeeper about the app
Quinn was talking about meanwhile as she
is driving Quinn suddenly sees a dark
figure causing her to Ram her vehicle
into another Matt then comes outside and
shows her his countdown app it turns out
he is also experiencing similar things
to discuss it further the two enter a
bar and think of a way to read the terms
and conditions of the app so Matt
convinces a delusional guy to download
the app and they go over to him when he
reaches the terms and conditions page
Quinn starts reading them it states that
the players have to accept their fate
thinking that demons are involved the
two go to the hospital to talk to the
priest however he tells them to visit
someone much more qualified and give
them his address as they are about to
leave Quinn is called by Amy while Matt
goes to the bathroom he then sees a
Barefoot child from beneath the stall
and asks him to go to another stall
afterwards as he washes his hands he
hears someone crying in one of the
Stalls and sees the kid again shortly
after the kid attacks Matt as the lights
go off and it disappears when another
person walks in the room meanwhile Amy
takes Quinn to a meeting with the HR
along with Dr Sullivan it turns out that
Sullivan lied to the HR saying that it
was actually Quinn who attacked him
while working the HR department then
proceeds to suspend Quinn which
infuriates her and storms off meanwhile
Matt seems distraught and keeps hearing
the voice of the thing that attacked him
shortly after they arrive at a church
and look for the man that the priest
pointed them towards after hearing them
out the priest recalls an ancient story
and to get a better idea of how the app
works he tells them to find someone to
hack the app for them to look at the
code so the two go to the mobile shop
and ask the shopkeeper Derek for help
Derek also finds the countdown clocks
for all the users including his own and
changes the parameters increasing his
life it's then revealed that Jordan has
also downloaded the app and so they
change all of their parameters
increasing their countdown clock
including Jordans but as she uses her
phone while eating her babysitter
confiscates it meanwhile Matt and Quinn
thanked Derek for his help and
afterwards she asks Matt to stay with
her that night after reaching home the
two have a short conversation and fall
asleep at midnight Quinn suddenly wakes
up after hearing something outside the
room however it turns out that Matt is
the one outside meaning the person in
bed with her is the demon she freaks out
and when Matt takes off the bed sheets
the demon disappears unfortunately both
mats and Quinn's countdown goes back to
the original number worried she calls
Jordan but is unaware about her phone
not being being with her meanwhile
Jordan hears her phone ring in the
babysitter's room and goes to get it
suddenly the lights start to Flicker and
she hears her dead mom talking and the
very next second the woman appears
luckily Quinn and Matt arrive in the
nick of time and rescue Jordan after
this the trio head to the priest there
he deduces from the app code that a
curse has been put on them the priest
then explains that in order to lift the
curse someone with the countdown app has
to either die early or alive longer than
the countdown so they naturally choose
the latter option and the priest blesses
some salt before making a holy Circle to
keep them safe from the demons after the
circle is complete Matt finds out he has
only two minutes left on the clock and
steps aside for a second Quinn
accompanies him where one thing leads to
another and the two share an emotional
kiss all of a sudden the lights go out
and all of them Rush inside the circle
the demon appears shortly after and is
planned it cannot enter the circle
suddenly Matt's phone starts to blare
and he begins to see visions of his
young dead brother who lures him out of
the circle the demon then immediately
pulls him outside the building and Quinn
runs after him but when the two reunite
Matt is abruptly run over by a car and
is killed she later finds that Jordan is
bleeding and rushes her to the hospital
there Quinn is approached by another
nurse who reveals that she too is a
victim of Dr Sullivan's abuse so Quinn
thinks of killing him as he too has the
countdown app which will hopefully lift
the curse later she manages to seduce
him in his office and tells him to
follow her to the closed section of the
hospital there she attempts to inject
Sullivan with a ton of morphine but is
stopped by Jordan who comes looking for
her suddenly the doctor is dragged Away
by the demon to stop Quinn from killing
him so she goes after the doctor while
Jordan checks her phone which reveals
that she has only two minutes left to
live meanwhile Quinn finds Sullivan and
is about to attack him but the demon
pushes her away allowing the doctor to
escape after a while the demon starts
chasing after Jordan just as her time is
about to end Quinn confronts it with a
syringe pushed against her skin the
demon impersonates her dead mother but
Quinn is faced and she injects herself
with the morphine as a result Quinn dies
before Jordan's time is up vanquishing
the demon once and for all Jordan rushes
to Quinn's dead body and surprisingly
finds a drug written on her arm with a
bottle and syringe in her pocket so
Jordan uses the syringe and injects it
into her arm bringing her back to life
the scene then cuts to some time in the
future where Quinn Jordan and her dad
pay respects to their mother's grave as
they're about to leave Quinn gets a
notification which says that the new
version of the countdown app has been
installed subscribe and hit that like
button to help our Channel grow turn the
notifications on so you won't miss any
of our new videos thanks for watching